bienvenue à part à l'automne si c'est
mélissa mollen depuis cette semaine
d'une question de dominique qui me
demandent les musées devrait-il de
redonner tous les objets autochtone qui
appartiennent à des communautés encore
existantes et comment dominique pas
question l excellente mais elle a un
historique très long qui serait dur
difficile de rentrer dedans complet mais
ce que j'expliquais c'est que une très
grande problématique avec les musées et
des fois l'acquisition que les musées
font des objets autochtone il ya des cas
extrêmes comme je pense à un
missionnaire aux états unis qui a créé
un espèce de mini musée dans son sous
sol
mais il le remplit en allant chercher
des objets des fois de manière
extrêmement illégales comme en allah
dans les tombeaux de personnes
autochtones et en ramenant les objets
illégalement au pays
aux etats unis mais ce n'est pas une
pratique qui est qui est ignorée des
musées parce que beaucoup d'objets dans
les musées ont été des fois acquis de
façon non respectueuses des communautés
autochtones
alors je pense des fois certains moto
techniques qui ont été volés dans
l'ouest en plein milieu de la nuit par
des explorateurs certains objets aussi
qui sont très difficiles a exposé parce
qu'on va parler d'ossements de personnes
qui ont été dans le fond ramener dans
des pays européens ou même dans des
musées canadiens ou américains
et ce sont quand même les restes de tête
est enceinte de ta culture imagine si on
allait chercher ta grand mapic ont
décidé de l'exposer au musée pour des
raisons culturelles ou sociales c'est
très difficile d'expliquer ça c'est
encore le principe même de dire est ce
qu'une momie c'est assez vu pour dire
qu'il ya plus de lien familial
ça c'est des questions que chaque nation
a le droit de répondre à sa manière
cependant j'ai beaucoup de travail qui a
été fait par les musées surtout quand on
pense aux recommandations par rapport à
la commission vérité réconciliation de
travailler avec les communautés
donc c'est certain que certaines
communautés voudrait avoir certains des
objets restitués
parce que ce sont des objets sacrés ou
des objets qui peuvent être utilisés
dans les cérémonies mais des fois c'est
difficile où c'est avoir une
comment choisir un lieu pour les
protéger pour les garder les restaurer
donc c'est important d'avoir des
ententes aussi avec les musées pour que
certains objets restent dans les musées
conservent leur statut d'objet muséal
mai puis cette sortie dans des occasions
spéciales par les communautés pour faire
des cérémonies
et justement cet échange le permet un
équilibre entre pratiques muséal
respectueuse et accessibilité à nos
objets ancestraux mais c'est certain que
c'est du cas par cas dans chaque musée
on parle même d'université qui ont des
objets ou des restants d'êtres humains
encore dans leur collection et qui ont
des difficultés à les laisser aller
parce que ils voient est l'objet muséal
et nous on voit l'objet culturel qui a
été volé donc c'est certain qu'il faut
qu'un processus s'engage entre les
communautés et les musées qui ont
certains des objets pour pouvoir donner
accessibilité et pour pouvoir faire en
même temps de l'éducation pour nos
jeunes pour qu'ils puissent voir les
objets qui font partie de leur culture
parce qu'il ya des objets un peu partout
qu'on ne voit plus loin puisqu'ils ont
été mis dans des musées alors dominique
merci beaucoup pour la question j'espère
que ça va vous intéresser sur justement
l'enjeu de la protection des objets
ancestraux et des pratiques muséal et
c'était pas nous envoyer des questions
n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos
je souhaite une très belle semaine